안녕하세요 오늘은 오래된 전통과
현대가 공존하는 을지로에
왔습니다네 을지로 오래 전부터 이런
낡은 건물들이 좀 많이 밀집되어
있었고 이런 인쇄소 아든 공구 조명
가게들이 밀집되어 있어서 전국에서
공구나 조명을 구매하기 위해서 여기
을지로를 많이 찾았습니다 그러다가
트렌드가 변하면서 온라인 구매가 좀
활성화되기 시작했고 이런 인쇄소든지
공구 조명 가게들이 나가기 시작하면서
공실이 많이 발생되었습니다 그러다가
임대료가 좀 많이 내려갔는데 임대료가
내려가다 보니까 이런 젊은 감각 있는
창업자들이 이쪽에 들어오면서 을지로
분위기가 좀 바뀌기 시작했고 레트로
감성과 지금 현대적인 분위기가
어우러져 젊은 사람들이 많이 찾는 어
그런 곳으로 각광을 받기 시작했습니다
을지로 상권이 좋게 된 이유는 다섯
가지가 있습니다 우선 첫 번째 을지로
3가와 사가 쪽은 접근성이 너무
좋습니다 그래서 서울시의 중심부에
위치하고 있고 2호선 3호선
5호선까치산역 합니다 어 많은
사람들이 역에서 나와서 이동하기가
되게 편한 위치에 있어 가지고 그
부분에 있어서 상권이 좀 확장된
부분이 있고 두 번째로는 저렴한
임대료를 꼽을 수 있습니다 기존에
이런 인쇄소든지 공구 상가가 낮은
임대료를 사용하고 있다 보니까 이런
젊은 창업가가 창업하기에 매우 좋은
조건이었습니다 그리고 세 번째로는
SNS 발달로 원래 기존의 상가라고
하면 목 좋은데 있었거든요 근데 지금
여기 을지로 골목 같은 경우에는 진짜
이면에 이면에 찾기도 힘들 정도로
진짜 간판도 없는 가게들도 많거든요
다 SNS 발달로 골목까지 상권이 좀
확장됐다고 보시면 될 거 같고네
번째로는 네트로 감성입니다 기존의
상권이라고 하면 뻔한 임차인과 뻔한
그런 프랜차이즈 업체들이 좀 많이
있어서 일반적인 상권은 좀 젊은
사람들이 많이 질리거든요 지금 을지로
같은 경우에는 좀 색다른 경험을 할
수 있는 이런 낡은 인쇄소가 있긴
하지만 그 옆에 되게 힙한 가게가
있다라는 이런 뭔가 레드로 감성을
요즘 젊은 사람들이 되게 좋아하거든요
그래서 그런 부분에 있어서 젊은
사람들이 좀 많이 찾는 거 같습니다
그 다섯 번째로는 저렴한 가격이 되게
중요한 부분인 거 같아요 그래서
임대료가 아무래도 저렴하다 보니까
가격이 되게 낮은 가게들이 많아요
그런 부분에 있어서 젊은 사람들이 좀
되게 찾아오기 좀 좋은 거 같습니다
임대료가 높다 보면 가격을 높게
책정할 수밖에 없거든요 근데 지금
을지로 같은 경우에는 아직까지
임대료가 그렇게 높지 않아서 좀
합리적인 가격 때문에 이런 젊은
사람들이 좀 많이 찾는 것도 있는 거
같습니다 사람들이 많이 찾으면
임대료가 또 높아지거든요 그래서을
로도 기존에는 아주 낮긴 했지만 지금
임대료가 조금씩 높아지고 있는 시기기
하거든요 그러다 보니까 이제
젠트리피케이션이 여기도 어날 여지가
조금 있을 것 같긴 합니다 여기 만약
임대료가 더 높아지면 아무래도 이런
가격을 높일 수밖에 없기 때문에 그
부분에 있어서 앞으로 좀 어떻게
변해야 할지 한번 좀 지켜보시면 좋을
것 같습니다네 그리고 여기 인근에
빌딩 투자 사례가 있는데 제가 직접
가서 어떤 빌딩에 매각됐고 특징들이
어떤 건지 제가 자세하게 설명드리도록
하겠습니다 가시죠
그래서 지금 매각사례 앞에 와 있는데
지금 뒤에 보이는 저 건물입니다
저건물이 작년에 51억 5천에 매각이
됐어요 돼지가 49평이고 연면적이
158편 있니다 그리고 지하 1층에
지상 4층 건물이고 1971년도에
지어서 건물이 굉장히 낡았어요 근데
제가 봤을 때는 위치가 그래도
괜찮아요 코너 변에 위치하고 있고
건물도 좀 되게 커 보이고 그리고
여기 을지로의 특징이 뭐냐면 여기가
다 이제 일반 상업지에 일반 상업지
보니까 임차인이 되게 좀 자유롭습니다
그래서 지금이 건물 지하도 위락
시설로 쓰고 있는데 이제 그런
임차인들 받을 수 있어요 그래서 그런
임차인들은 아무래도 임대료 수준이
되게 높습니다 그리고이 건물 같은
경우에는 제가 봤을 때 리모델링
하기는 되게 좋은 건물이에요 대지
평당가로 보면 한 약 1억 정도
되는데이 인근에 좀 도로 잘 접한
거는 대부분 다 이제 평당 1억
정도에 팔리더라 제가 봤을 때는
괜찮은 가격에 좀 매입하지 않았나
이렇게 생각을 합니다 그리고 무엇보다
여기가 다 상업 지어서 그런 용도
지역에 대한 메리트도 있는 거 같아요
아무래도 시설이라는 위락 시설이
임대료가 좋기 때문에 나중에 이제
을지로 건물을 매입할 때 그런 부분도
생각하시면 좋을 것
[음악]
같습니다 지금 두 번째 매각사례 앞에
와 있는데 저기 뒤에 보이는 저
건물입니다 돼지가 33평에 연면적이
59평 그리고 지상 2층 건물이에요
역 앞에 있어서 위치는 굉장히 좋은데
건물 면적은 좀 작습니다 돼지
33평의 저건물이 무려 53억 있니다
그래서 돼지 평당가로 봤을 때 1억
6천 정도 돼요 그래서 가격이
상당합니다 그래서 앞서 제가
설명드렸던 사례보다 가격은 비슷하긴
하지만 면적이 많이 줄어들었죠 그래서
연면적으로 봤을 때는 거의 1분
정도입니다 아무래도 위치가 좋다
보니까 가격이 좀 비싼 부분이 있는데
근데이 건물 같은 경우에는 사실
위치는 좋긴 하지만 현실적으로 좀
신축하기 좀 어려워요 건물 면적을
올리긴 좀 어려워서 지금 상태가
최적의 상태라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 어떻게 보면 59평 최대한
활용을 해야 돼요 그래서 지금 모습이
좀 최선의 상태 라고 보시면 될 거
같고 그래서 이건 뭐 개인적인
의견인데 만약에 비슷한 50억 금행
대라고 하면은 뭐 저 같으면은
아무래도 위치가 이게 더 좋긴
하더라도 저는 옆면적 큰 거
좋아하거든요 그 이면에 봤었던 그
코너 건물은 제 개인적으로 선택할 것
같습니다이 개인적인 의견이고 어
참고만 하시면 될 거 같습니다 근데
여기서 하나 또 설명드릴게 저기 옆에
지금 호텔 보이시죠 세라톤 호텔
수수계 중에 한 90% 다
외국인이라고 합니다 그래서 실제로
여기가 위치가 너무 좋다 보니까 뭐
명동 쪽에 가기 너무 편하고 든요
그래서 그러다 보니까 이쪽 인근으로
좀 숙소를 많이 잡는 거 같습니다
그리고 이제 을지로가 핫해지면서
외부인들도 좀 많이 오고 있어요 다른
지역에 이런 젊은 사람들도 많이
오면서 이제 입지적으로 너무 훌륭하기
때문에 뭐 외부인 그리고 이제 오피스
직장인 그리고 이제 외국인까지 이렇게
삼박자가 맞춰져 가지고 사람들이 많은
거
같습니다 여기 카페가 간판이 없어요
여기를 어떻게 찾아올까 할 정도로
공개되지 않은 찾기가 되게 어려운
곳입니다 근데 지금 보시면 알겠지만
꽉 찼어요 사람이 그 정도로 sns
보고 오는 젊은 사람들이 굉장히
많습니다 다 sns 보고 오신 거
같아요 아마 여기 지금 4층 맹
꼭대기에 있는데 임대료도 되게 낮을
거예요 임대료 수준도 되게 낮을
것으로 예상이 되고 그리고 여기 안에
보면은 인테리어 보시면은 예전에 그
공장으로 사용했던 그 날것 그대로 돼
있어요 뭐 인테리어 비용도 크게 안
들고 임대료도 되게 낮다 보니까 이런
젊은 사람들이 창업하기에 너무 좋은
환경 같아요 요즘 트렌드에 막 이게
가구 배치라 예전에 그런 네트로 감성
때문에 이런 젊은 사람들이 이렇게
sns 보고 많이 찾아오는 거
[음악]
같습니다 지로는 제가 가서 느낀 점은
예전에 낡았던 건물들이 좀 새로
바뀌는 모습을 좀 많이 봤고 그런
건물들을 그냥 부시고 신축하는게
아니라 예전 건물 그 모습 그대로를
리모델링해서 사용하는 부 분이 되게
좀 인상적이었고 을지로 현장을 가보면
을지로는 다른 상권과 비교해서는
확실히 경쟁력이 있다라고 생각이 들고
많은 사람들이 이런 부분 때문에 좀
더 앞으로 찾아오지 않을까 그렇게
생각을
합니다 저녁을 먹으러 이제 식당에
들어왔는데 뭔가 의지로만 그 느낌이
참 좋은 거 같습니다 좀 앞으로
전망을 좀 하자면 일단은 입지가 너무
좋아요 일지로 이가랑 삼가역이 너무
좋기 때문에 그리고 언덕길이나 내
막길이 없어서 접근성이 일단 너무
좋다는게 좋은 거 같고 두 번째로
여기 인근에 오피스가 많아요 저는
앞으로 조금 걱정인게 오피스 공급이
엄청 많이 돼요 이쪽 일대로 그래서
이게 만약에 지어지면 강남의 오피스도
좀 상당한 영향을 받을 것 같아
아무래도 강남보다는 임대료가 저렴하기
때문에 이쪽으로 좀 많이 몰려오지
않을까 생각을 합니다 아무래도 여기
인근에 오피스라는 이런 주거 시설이
생기면 이쪽 일대로 좀 사람들이
그래도 좀 오지 않을까 상권이 아마
영향을 좀 많이 받을
그런 부분에 있어서는 되게 좋을 거
같고 인근에 이런 재개발 예정이 좀
많이 되어 있거든요 여기가 이제
주어나 이런 오피스로 개발이 된다면
여기 일때도 좀 뭐 긍정적으로 영향이
잃지 않을까 이렇게 생각을 합니다
그리고 이제 무엇보다 여기 인근에
여러 상권들이 있거든요 북촌 한옥
마을이라 선동이라는 뭐 이태원이라
이런 데와 비교해서 경쟁력이 있어야
될 거 같아 지금 상태의 의치가
경쟁력이라고 생각하거든요이 강점을
좀잘 유지 한다라고 하면은 다른
상권과 좀 겹치지 않은 그 의지로만
특색이 있는 상권이 유지되지 않을까
그렇게 생각을 합니다 근데 여기를
만약에 재 개발한다고이 건물을 다
부신 다음에 무슨 복합 건물로 지으면
이제 큰일납니다 일반적인 그런 상권과
똑같이 만들어 놓으면이 을지로로 올
필요가 없거든요 지금이 모습 그대로
좀 의지로만 느낌을 좀 만들면 좋지
않을까 그렇게 생각을 합니다 자
앞으로 지로가 서울시 내에서도 좀
특색 있고 이런 젊은 사람들이 새로운
경험을 하 하기 위해서 여기 좋은
상권이라고 생각하기 때문에 여기
일대를 갑자기 개발하거나 뭐
주상복합을 만들거나 막 이러지 않은
이상은 긍정적으로 보고 있긴 합니다
근데 이제 한 가지 아셔야 될 거는
여기 건물이 워낙 오래되다 보니까
건폐율이 100% 넘은 건물들이
많아요 그런 부분을 조심히 보면 좋을
거 같고 건축 행위를 한다라고 했을
때는 꼭 사전에 안전 진단이라는 뭐
이런 부분을 확인하고 투자하시면 좋을
것 같습니다 그래서 오늘 영상은
여기까지 하고요 리딩은 역시 사
[음악]